con la llegada de Donald Trump a Miami
Florida donde se enfrentará a una
audiencia en la que le serán imputados
37 cargos por la retención ilegal de
documentos clasificados cientos de
fanáticos lo esperan frente a uno de sus
hoteles
Y es que la popularidad de Trump y el
partido republicano ha ido en aumento en
el estado antiguamente bastión de los
demócratas en especial a cada vez más
latinos lo apoyan y comparan la
situación del expresidente con la de
algunos opositores en Latinoamérica es
el que tiene la izquierda y el comunismo
que está ingresando a nuestro país y
quieren introducirnos quitando la
libertad de expresión y no lo vamos a
tolerar las pruebas presentadas por la
fiscalía no parecen suficientes para
ellos y algunos han amenazado con
recurrir a la violencia algo que ya ha
pasado en el país solo me arrodillo por
mi salvador me pondré en pie y moriré no
me importa no me importa algo que ha
hecho saltar las alarmas de la ciudad
que asegura estar preparada para las
protestas
en nuestra ciudad obviamente creemos en
la Constitución y creemos que las
personas deben tener derecho a
expresarse pero también creemos en la
ley y el orden y lo sabemos Esperamos
que este martes sea Pacífico alentamos a
las personas para que mantengan la calma
demostrando lo que sienten y vamos a
tener las fuerzas adecuadas necesarias
para asegurar eso
Y es que una vez más el discurso
incendiario de Trump que mantiene su
inocencia y Define los cargos en su
contra como una caza de brujas podrían
generar violencia a la ciudad sus
seguidores han asegurado planean
apoyarlo durante todo el proceso